certaines lois marque une époque du saut
de la grandeur ou de l'abondance
c'est une phrase de Pascal Brice
président de la Fédération des acteurs
de la solidarité dans sa dernière
tribune pour nous alerter sur les
conséquences de la loi qui nous est
présentée l'abandon chers collègues
c'est celui de la solidarité ce texte se
trompe de cible justile comme christophe
Robert le délégué général de la
Fondation Abbé Pierre dans un courrier
adressé il y a quelques jours à Gérard
lacher le président du Sénat ce sont les
causes du mal logement qu'il faut
combattre pas ceux qui en sont victimes
c'est une arme atomique qui va dans pas
résoudre le problème visé
mais créer des dégâts collatéraux dans
toute la société française subira les
conséquences cette abandon de la
solidarité est camouflé de manière plus
ou moins habile mais définitivement avec
une grotte violence derrière l'érection
du droit de propriété comme une valeur
absolue
afin d'éviter tout raccourci dans lequel
certains souhaitent parfois nous
enfermer je vais l'emblée et sans embage
nous ne revêtons pas en cause le droit
de propriété et sa portée
constitutionnelle
la propriété locative doit être et est
protégée d'autant que comme nous le
voyons dans nos covides populaires on
peut être propriétaire et fragilisé par
l'âge par la santé par le niveau de
revenus et dans nos rangs nous savons
aussi que les principes constitutionnels
doivent se concilier se concilier de
manière équilibrée équilibrée à
l'inverse de ce texte qui tel qu'il a
été voté par l'Assemblée nationale ne le
recherche pas d'ailleurs l'équilibre
c'est donc à nous ici dans cette
hémicycle de faire le travail qui a été
commencé par les rapporteurs le Conseil
constitutionnel dans une décision du 19
janvier 1995 à érigé au rôle d'objectifs
de valeurs constitutionnelles la
possibilité pour toute personne de
disposer d'un logement décent le
présenter texte quoi comme modifié par
notre commission pour éviter les
amalgames iniquent entre protection de
la propriété des domicile est un danger
une fausse solution
inefficace et antisociale il revient à
une criminalisation insupportable de la
précarité et de la pauvreté étudier
d'abord le dogue de droit de propriété
sans limite
je le ferai ou face à personne si je
rappelle combien dans cette hémicycle
celles et ceux si attacher un droit de
propriété absolue en par contre estimé
dans un passé récent que l'absolu lui
était finalement pas tant que ça lors de
l'étude du texte sur l'exprapo
l'expropriation des bières manifestement
l'abandon nous avons bien noté que le
droit de ne rien faire de sorbières
restez s'accro-saint quand il s'agit de
bien construire fini et entretenu qui
pourrait participer à l'hébergement des
malongés mais ne saurait être toléré
quand tu collectivité peut y avoir une
opportunité de développement c'est donc
un droit absolu à géométrie variable la
volonté de mélanger domicile locale
d'habitation locaux ayant d'autres
destinations nous poussent sur une porte
dangereuse cela déborde l'ambition d'un
texte qu'il a que faire de l'équilibre
entre les propriétaires les bailleurs et
les locataires et qu'il est mis en place
en 1989 constamment améliorée depuis et
protégé par tous les acteurs
institutionnels et professionnels du
secteur mais qui sera mis à mal et
détruit par ce texte une hypocrisiez la
tentative très maladroite et fragile
constitutionnellement d'après l'aveu
même du garde des sceaux de confort de
protection de la propriété et du
domicile le domicile est la propriété
sans protéger de manière différenciée et
pour tous les cas franchement triste et
scandaleux de propriétaire de pouvoir
intégrer leur domicile ce n'est pas le
manque de protection dans notre droit
qui est en jeu mais une méconnaissance
des bécanismes de protection le
président du Haut cohabiter pour le
droit au logement le rappelle dans un
courrier adressé aux membres du Sénat il
sauve que la plupart du temps les
propriétaires particuliers les plus
modestes sauf plutôt d'un manque de
moyens de la justice et d'accès aux
dispositifs de prévention des expulsions
plutôt que d'un droit inefficace
cette criminalisation des locataires en
difficulté elle est non seulement
totalement indécente mais inutilement
dirais-je car elle ne peut pas apporter
une solution à ce problème faire porter
la responsabilité d'un point de vue
aux personnes en difficulté que
l'État n'a pas pu traiter et
d'assainissement rare les mesures d'aide
sociale relatives à l'hébergement des
familles en graves difficultés
économiques ou de logement relève de la
responsabilité de l'État qui est parfois
trop défaillant les collectivités ne
peuvent se substituer à la puissance
publique nationale une décision récente
du Conseil d'État a rappelé que la
carrosse avérée prolongée de l'État est
caractérisée chambre des territoires
nous savons combien les collectivités
tentent de paliers quelquefois au
manquement de l'État si nombreux
particulièrement dans les besoins de
mise à l'abri quand elle le peuvent et
que l'État les laisse faire mais où est
ce gouvernement où est la politique du
logement être foi dansait toujours
reporté enlever du projet séparatisme
c'est l'arlésienne du président Macron
en 2018 celui-ci avait déclaré je veux
que nous puissions apporter à toi à
toutes celles et ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui sans abri en 2022 le
ministre délégué chargé du logement
Olivier Klein a réduit cet objectif aux
seules enfants et depuis monsieur le
ministre le locataire reste parce que
l'État est incapable de respecter ses
propres obligations en matière de droit
au logement ou à l'hébergement c'est une
phrase de Claire et Dole la Défenseur
des droits qui s'acquiète des
conséquences d'une adoption de la loi
pour des milieux des personnes déjà sur
le fil j'ai entendu et apprécier les
discussions aux conditions chers
collègues qui ont appuyé le besoin de
prise en charge des locataires en
difficulté via l'établissement de bilan
social des locataires mais qui pourra
effectuer ces bilans où sont les moyens
pour les préfectures d'accompagner ces
personnes en difficulté les débats de la
haine ont permis de rappeler le manque
de moyens pour les travailleurs sociaux
du 115 le manque de place d'hébergement
d'urgence chaque soir en France 5000
personnes appellent en vin le 115 dans
l'espoir d'une place en hôtel ou au
foyer d'urgence à Marseille
25% de la population vit sous le seuil
de pauvreté à peine un appel sur trois
abouti où est l'état et puis toutes ces
histoires aussi tristes les unes que les
autres de petits propriétaires qui sont
dans l'impossibilité de récupérer leur
domicile
occupé illégalement sont souvent le
reflet de méconnaissance ou dix actions
des services de l'État médiatique et
insupportable toutes ces situations ont
été résolues sans nécessité de modifier
la loi
étant capacité étant capable de trouver
un chemin pour protéger à la fois les
propriétaires les locataires les
personnes mal logées ou à la rue les
moyens de protéger les petits
propriétaires existent des mesures de
protection équilibrée pour les
propriétaires et les locataires
pourraient être à forcés comme la
garantie loyers mais rien dans
l'écriture du texte ni même ça
réécriture moins délirante par la
Commission de notre assemblées ne
montrent que le but de cette loi et la
protection de ces petits bailleurs
parfois démuni face aux démarches le but
affiché est punitif la conséquence la
punition de famille en difficulté une
criminalisation de ceux qui subissent la
précarité ceux qui souffle du mal
logement et pour qui peu de solutions
sont offertes plus de 4 millions de
personnes sont mal logées 300 abris dans
42 000 enfants enfants lessive sont
édifiants les causes sont multiples
complexes mais la crise actuelle inédite
entraîne une accélération de la
paupérisation des polices populations
fragiles les solutions à cette détresse
qui poussent les personnes dans la rue
dans des situations dépayées ce que la
proposition de loi appelle des
occupations frauduleuses sont absorbes
du texte de loi la notion de
pénalisation de prison pour des
problèmes d'impayés est une notion
insupportable vous de plus vous ne
pouvez plus payer votre loyer votre bail
résilié et pourtant vous occuper encore
votre logement faute d'autres solutions
que la rue en prison la prison pour
dette est de retour dans notre
République serions-nous prêts à ériger
cette dette comme la plus criminelle au
sein de notre société au-delà de la
réflexion insensée ils vont les
solvabilité de loyer comme différentes
des autres insolvabilités quelle est la
finalité de cette pénalisation par une
peine d'emprisonnement toutes sanction
financières sous forme d'amende aura
aussi pour conséquence de créer un
cercle vicieux maintenant les
occupations les occupants illégaux dans
une précarité à part une valeur
symbolique de punition qui sera gagnant
que gagnera le propriétaire qui sera qui
aura encore moins de chance de recouvrer
sa dette le président du haut-combité
pour le droit au logement d'où l'a
rappelé on privilégiant l'expulsion les
propriétaires auront beaucoup moins de
possibilités de recouvrer leurs dettes
et les locataires rejoindront les robes
et sans domicile fixe ou des sans-abris
la précarité le problème de base avec un
contexte actuel incertain l'inflation
l'accroissement des contrats précaires
l'augmentation des factures énergétiques
la diminution des adaptés de chômage les
situations de défaut de paiement se
multiplieront les dispositifs de bises à
l'abri d'hébergement d'urgence
d'application du DALO ne sont pas
suffisamment Bize en oeuvre et sont
pourtant les solutions que vrai texte
sur le sujet aurait dû prendre en compte
tout au contraire des dispositions de ce
texte dans la Fondation Abbé Pierre
estime qu'elles vont provoquer jusqu'à
30000 décisions d'expulsion
supplémentaires soit autant de personnes
qui risquent de se retrouver à la rue
mes chers collègues
c'est avec une certaine fascination que
j'observe la tentation disons-le à peu
démagogique de positionnement sur le
droit de propriété que personne encore
une fois ne remettent en cause ces
positionnements fortement affirmées des
fordus par certains ici sont pourtant
variables comme j'ai déjà pu l'évoquer
dans le cas de l'expropriation des
bières d'État d'abandon manifeste un
jour ce droit de propriété est absolu un
dont il ne l'est pas c'est notre devoir
de garantir les droits et la protection
des plus vulnérables si la loi telle
qu'elle nous est arrivé de l'assemblée
est une caricature dans la chirurgère de
déséquilibre et de pénalisation à
outrance faisant un abalga pour le coup
coupable entre protection de la
propriété protection du domicile entre
squat et incapacité de payer si je
reverse les rapporteurs d'avoir perçu
certains risques et de les avoir réduits
de leurs abonnements je termine la ligne
rouge ou la crimination
contre la mention c'est moi qui décide
Monsieur benaroche Merci
vous n'êtes pas rapporteur donc c'est
bon même Catherine procacia contre la
motion pour 10 minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le garde
des sceaux monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues ce soir c'est un anniversaire
et oui je ne peux que penser à la nuit
du 31 janvier 2007 il y a quasiment 16
ans jour pour jour j'étais bien seul
dans cette hémicycle pour parler des
squatteurs des sites Internet qui déjà à
l'époque délivraient un mode d'emploi et
j'expliquais à mes collègues de
différents bancs qu'il fallait aussi
penser à la personne locataire ou
propriétaire qui se retrouvaient à la
rue grâce à squatter
dans la nuit j'ai reçu des manifestants
une maladie des manifestants du dalle de
droit au logement de Jeudi Noir
et ils ont convenu avec moi que mon
amendement qui est devenu l'article 38
de la loi d'Allo était acceptable s'il
se limitait au squat de l'habitation
principale telle est l'histoire de
d'amendement 38 et là cet amendement que
vous avez de nombreuses fois évoqué
monsieur le garde des Sceaux a rarement
été mis en oeuvre et il a été pendant
très longtemps très peu appliqué par les
préfets
11 ans après autre petit pas qu'en
soutenu par la rapporteur de la loi Elan
le Sénat puis la CMP ont adopté mon
amendement qui précisait que la trêve
hivernale ne s'appliquait pas au
squatteur là contre la vie du garde des
Sceaux de l'époque qui disait que ça
tombait sous le sens mais une fois que
ça a été écrit c'est allé beaucoup mieux
comme j'ai pu le dire en 2021 à
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne et Henri
Leroy quel bonheur de voir la relève
enfin assurée que je n'étais plus la
seule à souligner les iniquités du droit
pour cet acte d'ailleurs si le texte de
2021 comme l'a dit notre rapporteur
avait été inscrit à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale nous n'aurions
peut-être pas aujourd'hui besoin de ce
nouveau débat
il ne faut pas oublier non plus que la
notion de squat a été étendue aux
résidences secondaires depuis la loi
ASAP et que depuis un an l'intervention
des commissaires de justice devrait
faciliter la procédure et quel plaisir
monsieur le garde des sceaux de vous
entendre reconnaître que le squat est un
débit nous n'avons pas toujours eu le
plaisir en tout cas au Sénat d'entendre
des gardes des sceaux l'affirmer
à mes collègues écologistes qui
remettent en cause cette PPL j'affirme
que amender avec beaucoup de
circonscriptions
circonspection des formations par nos
deux rapporteurs elle établit bien la
distinction entre squatteur et locataire
et je leur demande avez-vous été un jour
réellement en face d'une personne qui à
son retour de l'hôpital ou d'un voyage
ne peut plus rentrer chez elle et à
laquelle on demande de justifier que
c'est bien son domicile alors qu'elle a
non demande rien nos squatteurs et
qu'elle a tous ces documents peut-être
détruit à l'intérieur de son domicile je
remercie à cette occasion la commission
qui a repris un de mes amendements
récurrents qui avaient d'ailleurs été
adoptés en 2021 par le Sénat qui prévoit
que le préfet peut solliciter et doivent
solliciter l'administration fiscale pour
les titres de propriété
préoccupations légales du logement
puisque ce ne sont pas que des
propriétaires mais aussi des locataires
qui parfois ne peuvent pas rentrer chez
eux
mais collègues porteurs de la motion des
recevabilité argue que l'on ne peut
qu'on ne pénètre pas dans le domicile
d'autrui par plaisir et que chacun doit
disposer d'un domicile descend c'est un
argument que nous sommes nombreux à
comprendre mais je demande est-il normal
dans ce cas que les cellules les
serrures soient changées tout comme très
rapidement le nom de la du titulaire de
la quittance d'électricité et que les
squatteurs refusent de partir quand les
propriétaires ou les locataires
légitimes leur demandent et même après
un jugement de justice quand il ne
dégrade pas les lieux est-il normal que
les décisions de justice rendu à la
faveur des propriétaires du logement
parfois après plusieurs années ne soient
pas appliquées ce laxisme ne fait
qu'entretenir les squatteurs dans leur
sentiment d'impunité
et non monsieur benaroche tous les cas
ne sont pas réglés les cas que nous
voyons à la télévision ou dans la radio
ne sont pas tous les cas et ils ne sont
pas si exceptionnels que ça le droit au
logement existe je l'affirme mais il
doit s'appliquer à tous y compris au
titulaire du logement c'est mon intime
conviction
j'estime aussi que les propriétaires
évincées par les squatteurs devraient
aussi pouvoir être relogées et
réellement indemniser si le préfet
décide de ne pas exécuter une décision
de justice
votez la motion d'y recevabilité de mes
collègues ce serait rayer les avancées
attendues depuis longtemps comme
l'accélération de la procédure
contentieuse locative ou celle apportée
par la commission qui distingue bien
squatteur locataire qui ne plaît plus et
volontairement qui ne perd plus et qui
libère les propriétaires de leur
responsabilité pour l'entretien de bien
auquel ils ne peuvent plus accéder et
s'il y a je nous savons tous des
propriétaires indélicats il y a aussi
des locataires indélicats rééquilibrer
les droits permettra je l'espère de
remettre sur le marché de la location de
nombreux logements toutes ces raisons
font que le groupe républicain que je
remercie de m'avoir donné la parole pour
défendre ce texte votera contre la
motion des recevabilités merci chers
collègues quelle est la vie de la
Commission sur un porteur
mes chers collègues nos collègues
souhaitent opposer l'exception d'y
recevabilité considérant que la
proposition de loi contre vient à nos
grands principes et notamment à
l'objectif à valeur constitutionnelle
d'accès au logement la Commission ne
partage pas cette analyse le texte issu
de ces travaux contient plusieurs
dispositions qui viennent justement
prévenir les expulsions et améliorer
l'accompagnement social des locataires
en difficulté donc la commission a émis
un avis défavorable merci quelle est la
vie du gouvernement c'est le ministre
merci madame la Présidente ce soir après
la séance j'irai m'installer chez
Monsieur benaroche
avec toute mon équipe
et immédiatement je ferai en sorte de
changer les serrures
et comme le font certains squatteurs je
mettrai une petite affichachette à la
fenêtre pour vous dire que si jamais par
ephraction vous voulez récupérer votre
bien je vous ferai poursuivre on marche
sur la tête
en marche en marche sur la tête il y a
des gens qui ont bossé toute leur vie je
prenais tout à l'heure l'exemple de
cette femme qui part à l'Ehpad et alors
vous savez il y a des professionnels
d'abord il y a sur internet comment
squatter on a vu il y a tout un tout un
truc qui s'est mis en place mais on met
un petit morceau de papier sur la porte
et quand on constate qu'il a pas bougé
ça veut dire que c'est inoccupé alors
parce que la dame est à l'Ehpad parce
que le couple est parti en vacances et
puis d'autres viennent là oui oui c'est
une infraction et ça doit être une
infraction je vous ai fait plaisir
madame la sénatrice c'est franchement ce
que je pense
c'est pas ce qui a pu être dit par
certains de mes prédécesseurs mais enfin
vous rentrez chez les gens ça devient
votre domicile vous n'avez plus le
respect de rien moi je veux bien et non
mais attendez 2 secondes et au nom et au
nom du dogmatisme au nom de l'idéologie
vous trouvez ça normal
et ben alors j'irai pas chez le sénateur
benaroche et c'est vous c'est c'est
la parole
vous aurez votre temps de parole
merci
alors
je vais consulter
na sur l'exception d'y recevabilité
monsieur Savoldelli
merci madame la Présidente on va passer
à un moment avec les convictions les
passions des uns et des autres même si
on le garde des sceaux moi je vous
demande pas de venir chez moi
vous voyez ce que je veux dire non je
pense que non vous voyez vous êtes pas
calme
vous étiez vous aviez plus d'assurance
quand vous parlez tout seul ici il y a
un hémicycle on a une diversité ouais
ouais d'accord ouais oui faites de
l'emphase tu es d'accord
mais bon on voit votre récit de venir
chez un parlementaire enfin franchement
le sujet est trop important donc je vais
vous donner une explication il y a
évidemment une argumentation opposable à
ce que je vais dire
mais je vais pas partir d'un récit d'un
roman de je ne sais quelle histoire
voilà je vous dis mais c'est opposable
moi je pense que la question d'y
recevoirbilité nous allons la voter je
vous dire pourquoi et on va y revenir
après avec la question préalable de
manière calme et extrêmement
respectueuse il y a un problème de
déséquilibre à mes yeux aux yeux de
notre groupe peut-être que nous avons
tort entre deux droits qui sont à la
fois
les droits à temps les droits à la
liberté et les droits fondamentaux
garantis par la Constitution dans lequel
il y a le droit au logement nous pensons
nous pensons excusez de nous penser
que il y a un déséquilibre dans la façon
dont est abordé la question des squats
et des impayés avec un mélange de genre
qui n'a pas lieu d'être et un
déséquilibre sur la question des
libertés et des droits fondamentaux
entre le propriétaire et le locataire
c'est un point de vue quand même qui
s'entend et c'est pourquoi notre groupe
soutiendra l'y recevabilité qui est
proposé par notre collègues du groupe
Écologie Les Verts voilà et
tranquillement
merci Madame Martigues
merci madame la Présidente comme nous
collègues du groupe écologiste nous
trouvons cette proposition de loi
irrecevable et c'est à juste titre que
cette émotion rappelle dans son objet la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel du
19 janvier 1995 et le vent aura
d'objectif de valeur constitutionnelles
la possibilité tout pour toute personne
de disposer d'un logement décent ce qui
prendront la peine de relire cette
décision verront que les sages sites des
passages du Préambule de la Constitution
de 1946 qu'il paraît essentiel de
répéter ici ce soir la nation assure à
l'individu à la famille les conditions
nécessaires à leur de développement et à
le garantit à tous le droit d'obtenir de
la collectivité des moyens convenables
d'existence y compris lorsqu'une
personne un être humain se trouve dans
l'incapacité de travailler en raison de
son état physique ou de la situation
économique dès lors notre groupe
s'interroge sur un point particulier les
rédacteurs de proposition de loi
estime-t-il que le fait de prévoir une
peine d'emprisonnement pour punir
quelqu'un de marrant encore dans son
logement après avoir dû faire face à
l'impossibilité d'en payer son loyer et
la manière la plus adéquate pour notre
nation d'assurer à l'individu à la
famille les conditions nécessaires à
leur développement des moyens
convenables d'existence parce que nous
trouvons cette proposition de loi ni
recevable ni acceptable et encore moins
soutenable pour toutes les Françaises et
tous les Français notre groupe votera
cette motion et parce que aussi cette
prochaine projet de loi est
déséquilibrée introduit un déséquilibre
merci
Monsieur Bonhomme
bon simplement merci un président moi
simplement je lis le texte de
l'exception du responsabilité je trouve
qu'il est effectivement d'une grande
violence dans les propos parce que
parler de graves atteintes aux libertés
publiques d'une primauté soi-disant
absolue du droit du droit de propriété
et invoquer le logement décent comme si
c'était un permis et un sauve conduit à
bafouer les droits les plus élémentaires
du droit de propriété c'est quand même
une drôle d'interprétation parce que
monsieur benaroche vous manquez pas de
référence c'est quand même le premier
des droits qui a été affirmé en 1789
c'est pas rien c'est pas rien au même
titre que la sûreté ou même titre que
l'égalité de l'homme en droit au même
titre que la liberté la résistance à
l'oppression alors maintenant vous
invoqué le droit au logement qui certes
et tout à fait
admissible mais il y a quand même une
primauté de droit du droit dans son
exercice du droit au logement que vous
n'y est absolument et invoquer la crise
du logement à tout propos qui est une
réalité mais je ne vois pas en quoi vous
allez jusqu'à complètement ce droit
absolu est ce droit naturel que le droit
de propriété qui a été rappelée en 1789
au point que législateur enfin plutôt
les députés de l'Assemblée constituante
à l'époque en ont fait le premier
article et qui a figure en rédaction et
qui a figuré à l'article 17 de la
création de l'homme c'est quand même
quelques rappels qui sont nécessaires à
ce stade de la discussion
merci chers collègues alors je
ah oui monsieur le ministre pardon je
vous avais oublié je suis vraiment
désolé
madame la Présidente je veux rassurer
tout le monde répondre très brièvement à
votre interpellation monsieur le
sénateur en réalité
j'ai pas voulu vous offenser mais ce que
j'ai dit sur un ton un peu badin
peut-être n'aurais-je pas dû mais c'est
exactement ce qui se passe le droit au
logement dont vous faites les le fervent
défenseur il existe mais c'est pas
pousse-toi là que je m'y mette ça peut
pas être sage je suis désolé je suis je
suis désolé et tout à l'heure je l'ai
dit je voulais je voulais faire un mot
un mot d'humour en tous les cas moi
amical adresse du sénateur Belange vous
l'avez pris pour quelque chose
d'offensant et si c'est le cas je vous
présente les excuses mais c'est ça le
squat c'est je trouve un logement vide
il n'est pas à moi au nom du droit au
logement je vais au fond m'y installer
j'interdis ensuite aux propriétaires de
récupérer son bien
bon je sais pas la propriété c'est pas
sale c'est pas moche c'est consacré
aussi par notre Constitution il faut le
rappeler et moi je trouve que ce texte
il a le mérite d'être un texte équilibré
voilà entre naturellement le droit au
logement mais également le droit
constitutionnel à la propriété privée et
les situations que nous avons vu c'est
en dernier au travers d'un certain
nombre de reportages sont à proprement
parler
inacceptable
inacceptable vous avez ces jours
derniers des gens qu'on a vu qui dorment
sur leur terrain dans leur caravane
parce que l'appart qui est le leur ils
ont bossé toute leur vie est occupé par
des gens qui ont décidé que le droit au
logement surpassé tous les autres droits
enfin pardon mais moi je ne peux pas
être sur cette position là
merci alors je vais consulter le Sénat
sur l'exception du recevabilité je
rappelle que l'adoption de cette notion
entraînerait le rejet du texte en
discussion la vie de la Commission et la
vie du gouvernement est contre la motion
donc qui est pour la motion
qui est contre
qui s'abstient la motion n'est pas
adoptée nous passons à la discussion de
la motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable
madame Eliane assassy les membres du
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste on distribué sous le numéro 6
tendante à opposer la question préalable
au texte en discussion et la parole est
à Monsieur Pascal ça vole d'Elli pour la
motion et pour 10 minutes
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
je commence bien j'ai peur parler de
président de la République 2017 Emmanuel
Macron il déclare
je le cite je le cite la première
bataille Emmanuel Macron la première
bataille c'est de loger tout le monde
dignement
je ne veux plus d'ici la fin de l'année
avoir des femmes et des hommes dans les
rues dans les bois ou perdus c'est une
question de dignité c'est une question
d'humanité et d'efficacité là aussi fin
de citation
une question donc quelle est la place
qui accorde cette proposition de loi à
la dignité des plus vulnérables
depuis la création du droit au logement
inscrite dans la Constitution qui permet
l'expulsion sans jugement du domicile
occupé illicitement les réformes
successives en matière d'expulsion sans
jugement du domicile
occupé ce sont renforcés
d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure
ces réformes ont été alimentées de faits
divers pour beaucoup je m'excuse
beaucoup sur médiatisés donnant
l'impression que les phénomènes du squat
et des impayés de loyer d'ailleurs
injustement assimilé depuis tout à
l'heure injustement allez on fait un
amalgame entre les squats et les impayés
de loyer auraient pris une ampleur
considérable on serait face à un tsunami
on serait dans un quasiment dans un
régime d'occupation avec Kedi et
pourtant mes chers collègues nous sommes
loin d'être laxiste en la matière mais
ces phénomènes je m'excuse restent quand
même très rare certains ne veulent pas
le reconnaître le squat est pas toujours
est loin d'être la première issue voulue
par les personnes
c'est une solution forcée qui découle de
l'incapacité de l'État alors là bon moi
je veux bien qu'il faille pas en parler
mais à la mise à l'abri à l'accès au
logement de tous vous me direz monsieur
le minisquin si je je me trompe je crois
que sur l'exercice 2022 vous avez
construit 84000 logements sociaux c'est
ça
il dit oui donc c'est veut dire que on
dit la même chose et par contre 84000
logements sociaux quand on regarde il
faudra à peu près en construire 150 000
pendant 10 ans tous les ans
vous venez d'envoyer une missive au
préfet sur la question du froid avec les
préfets etc je vais vous parler tout à
l'heure de combien de temps on met à
avoir un hébergement d'urgence 75 mais
vous le savez donc donc pourquoi je vous
dis tout ça parce qu'on peut pas ignorer
cette question des réponses de l'État
si on veut pas de gens à la rue et
privés du droit et il convient de
souligner juridiquement que l'occupation
illicite d'un bien immobilier porte le
plus souvent une atteinte réparable au
droit de propriété le propriétaire peut
déjà obtenir une indemnisation
satisfaisante des loyers impayés ou des
dégâts causés par les occupants sans
droits ni titre pourquoi cette loi fait
l'impasse sur des dispositifs déjà
existants en fin de compte l'enjeu de
cette proposition de loi est élevé le
droit de propriété à finalité lucrative
au rang de valeurs suprême voilà la
question et c'est normal qu'on en
débatte
une valeur qui aux yeux de ce texte doit
primer sur tous les autres principes y
compris celui de la sauvegarde de la
dignité humaine car oui le but avoué de
cette proposition de loi est aggraver le
déséquilibre de la relation entre le
bailleur et le locataire et au détriment
de ce dernier et attendant l'homo est
dur le mot est dur mais on y viendra à
criminaliser les locataires les plus en
difficulté face aux intentions de cette
proposition de loi qui ne sont pas ou
peu en adéquation avec les réalités
économiques et sociales de notre pays je
pense qu'une piqûre de rappel s'impose
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste dénonce d'ailleurs
l'incapacité de l'État à respecter ces
obligations en matière de droit au
logement aujourd'hui je vous le dis
l'urgence est d'éviter que davantage de
personnes et de famille en situation de
précarité se retrouve à la rue nous
nions pas qu'en France ce n'est qu'une
fois tous les cinq jours qu'on peut être
logé par le 115 c'est ça monsieur le
ministre
non c'est beaucoup moins je vais
vérifier dans mon beau département le
Val-de-Marne si c'est moi ok
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste et convaincu que prévenir les
drames humains
tout en protégeant le droit des
propriétaires donc nous posons pas les
choses regardons ce qu'on appelle
l'intérêt général nous pensons nous
qu'il faut remettre sur pied la garantie
universelle de loyer
voilà de renforcer les moyens
d'hébergement et de relancer la
construction de logements sociaux
voilà tout l'inverse de ce qui est
proposé dans cette loi mes chers
collègues nous devons nous rendre compte
de la gravité de cette proposition nous
avons si on la vote on va appliquer pour
la première fois des locataires en
situation d'un pays de loyer des
dispositions habituellement réservées
aux occupations illicites résultant
d'une intrusion avec à la clé avec à la
clé une peine de prison ah bah c'est
marqué vous le dites et moi je vais vous
dire nos prisons j'espère que vous êtes
d'accord avec moi monsieur le garde des
sceaux sont plus que surpeuplés
j'apprends par exemple que dans la
plupart des prisons on atteint des taux
de surpeuplement allant de 140 à 160%.
c'est pas faux non plus ça fait quand
même pas mal de vérité quand même avec
qui sont quand même ici exprimés et sous
le prétexte détourné de protéger les
petits propriétaires face au squat de
leur domicile pourtant déjà puni par la
loi d'un an de prison et de 30000 euros
d'amende et d'une expulsion sans
jugement 48 heures la proposition de loi
s'attaquent en réalité à toute personne
toute personne en situation de provoquer
une balle logement ou confronter un
accident de la vie en plus d'être
incohérente avec les intentions
affichées le gouvernement en matière
d'expulsion de logement et de lutte
contre les marchandes sommeil tout ça ça
passe à la trappe on en parle pas et
aujourd'hui et ça a été dit par la
fondation de l'abbé Pierre il faut
construire 150 000 logements donc
l'absence de la politique
gouvernementale et aussi au coeur du
débat que nous avons aussi ce soir mais
aussi excusez-moi d'en parler je sais
que c'est pas ça va peut-être être une
sorte de cavalier législatif mais dans
la question du logement il y a la
question de l'autonomie financière donc
il y a la question des salaires ben
ouais ben ouais elle s'invite aussi dans
cette discussion là et ouais c'est vrai
du point d'indice dans la fonction
publique etc il y a l'inflation
mais vous vous pouvez aller chez
l'habitant je vous invite à la maison
mais vous n'avez pas de problème
financiers quand même pour avoir un
logement on est bien d'accord ok bon
donc il a un disque table que les
retards de loyer s'il n'y a pas des
efforts dans ce domaine il va y avoir
mes chers collègues plus en plus de
retard de paiement des loyers qui vont
exploser
s'il y a pas une réforme des aides au
logement il y aura forcément plus de de
problèmes j'étais encore avec des gens
moi dans ma vie dans une cité ils ont
acheté trois quatre cinq radiateurs ils
ont la facture d'énergie qui a explosé
mais franchement mais je crois que je
sais pas où on est il va y avoir un
problème d'impayés très rapidement
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre du
Logement je vous le dis par exemple une
proposition constructive aurait été ici
de relever la PL des charges là on va
aider les gens les plus modestes à
pouvoir subvenir au paiement de leur
loyer vous savez le poids que prennent
les charges dans la question du coup
pour payer son loyer donc voilà je
voulais vous dire que on est aussi dans
une situation où on assiste à un nombre
de coupures
ou de baisse d'énergie en termes de coût
pour l'eau pour l'énergie franchement
c'est pas le moment de de mettre cette
loi là au moment où il y a tant de gens
qui vont être exclus par nature puisque
de toute façon ils vont avoir des
factures qui ne peuvent pas payer
donc ça va être on va se retrouver dans
une situation excusez-moi je considère
comme assez explosive et n'oublions pas
que la privation de domicile peut être
également alors je sais que là on va me
dire ça fait un peu de sociologie des
sciences humaines mais bon
vous êtes cavalier comme ministre
franchement allons-y qui me dit oui
allez vas-y parle de ça bah je vous en
parler ouais le fait de pas avoir de
domicile sur le garde des sceaux ça peut
être une étape de désaffiliation sociale
vous le savez bien et qui conduit aux
formes les plus graves d'exclusion et
mes chers collègues comme le swing la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
dans son arrêt en date du 17 octobre
l'arrêt dit witterstein France la perte
d'un domicile entraîne souvent des
atteintes à d'autres droits cruciaux je
cite pour l'identité de la personne
l'autodétermination de celle-ci son
intégrité physique et morale le maintien
de ses relations sociales ainsi que la
stabilité et la sécurité de sa position
au sein de la société donc on est sur un
sujet extrêmement important ainsi la
procédure pénale visant réprimer le
comportement des occupants en cas de
violation de domicile ou de dégradation
de bien peut entraîner des
interpellations mais elle ne peut en
aucun constituer un mode d'expulsion
pourtant l'article premier 1a de la
proposition de loi en permettant que le
délit violation du domicile soit
constituée lorsqu’une personne pénètre
légalement dans un logement mais s'il
maintient illicitement autorise à
recours plus large et sur une durée
presse illimitée de la procédure de
flagrance une procédure pénale qui est
ici un mode d'expulsion et encore une
fois nous sommes face à une disposition
ni nécessaire ni proportionnée notre
groupe dénonce ainsi une proposition
définitivement dangereuse et ce dieu est
sur de multiples droits fondamentaux et
en effet comme le rappelle le président
de la Convention nationale de laïque des
droits de l'homme monsieur burguru cette
proposition de loi fait posée sur les
associations qui travaillent auprès des
personnes mal logées ou sans abri le
délit de propagande ou publicité visant
à inciter à l'occupation sans titre nous
craignons pour leur liberté d'expression
les associations risquent d'être sous le
joug d'une condamnation délictuelle en
raison des reportage ou dénonciation je
n'aurais pas la parole c'est bon c'est
bon chers collègues vous aurez d'autres
moments pour vous exprimer je vous
remercie la parole est à Madame Valérie
Boyer contre la motion et pour 10
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 2 de la Déclaration des droits
de l'homme et des citoyens est clair le
but de tout association politique et la
conservation des droits naturels et
imprescriptibles de l'homme ses droits
sont la liberté la propriété la sûreté
et la résistance à l'oppression
même si le droit de propriété a une
valeur constitutionnelle nous sommes
toujours face à des violations de
domicile et d'occupation des biens
immobiliers par des squatteurs pourquoi
vouloir revenir sur ses acquis de la
Révolution c'est paradoxal et une fois
encore alors que nous tenons à obtenir
plus de justice parce que lutter contre
la spoliation de la propriété c'est
obtenir plus de justice et de fermeté
vous nous opposez l'humanité comme si
les deux étaient incompatibles alors que
c'est l'inverse comme si nous devions
faire preuve d'humanité envers ceux qui
ne respectent pas la loi au détriment du
droit des propriétaires où est
l'humanité quand on se polie les
personnes
en effet de quelles propriétaires
parle-nous et nous en avons vous en avez
parlé monsieur le ministre et j'étais
ébahi de voir que pour une fois nous
étions d'accord nous parlons de
retraités qui ont économisé toute leur
vie nous parlons de jeux de
propriétaires qui se sont endettés pour
s'offrir un 3 pour y fonder une famille
nous parlons de famille aussi à qui on
vole leur souvenir nous parlons de rêves
brisés par des individus qui ne se
pensent parfois au-dessus des lois le
droit au logement ce n'est pas celui de
voler ou de détruire c'est tout à fait
l'inverse nous parlons de ces familles
qui souvent
utilisent les failles du droit et je
veux remercier souvent la presse qui se
fait l'écho de situations dramatiques
qui ont été évoquées ici dans des
plaises à certaines nous parlons souvent
de propriétaires bien modestes je
voudrais vous citer quelques exemples en
2020 après un tour du monde écourté pour
des raisons de santé Maryse et Pierre
avait voulu retourner vivre dans leur
maison louer le temps du voyage mais la
nouvelle habitante refusait de quitter
les lieux elle c'est essayer de payer le
loyer et les charges et il y a quelques
jours à Pamiers dans l'Ariège à 75 ans
Georgette pensez vivre une retraite
heureuse dans une petite maison qu'elle
s'est tachée il y a plus de 20 ans en
centre-ville et elle explique
aujourd'hui dans la presse que l'homme
qui avait mené les travaux de rénovation
refusaient de quitter les lieux à
Mazingarbe dans le Pas-de-Calais une
maison d'arrivera squatter saccagé
pendant plusieurs jours juste après les
fêtes de Noël pire encore les
propriétaires étaient même séquestrés
les squators sont même revenus à deux
reprises ensuite pour voler la
nourriture dans le réfrigérateur de la
victime ça peut peut-être vous faire
sourire mais ces situations sur
humainement dramatiques Mégane qui a
vérité d'une maison squattée à
fraissinville dans la Somme en octobre
2022 elle avait ému les Français en
parlant de son combat pour la récupérer
contraint de s'installer d'installer une
tente d'accrocher des banderoles et des
pancartes devant sa maison pour dénoncer
l'absurdité de la situation une
propriétaire de 24 ans à la rue et le
squatteur à l'abri elle espérait faire
évoluer la situation avant la fin de la
trêve hivernale le premier avril 2023
elle dénonçait la lenteur administrative
concernant le jugement d'expulsion et en
ce début d'année son constat est amer je
la cite pour la maison malheureusement
il n'y a aucun changement puisqu'il
n'est pas expulsable avant la fin de la
Trave hivernale évoque-t-elle où est
l'humanité malheureusement ces cas
médiatisés ne sont pas les seuls il y en
a de nombreux autres Émilie pour un
logement de Digne et compréhensible
excusez la destruction ou la spoliation
du bien d'autrui pour moi ne l'est pas
et ce je trouve ça à la fois incongru et
injuste ces Athènes manifestent au droit
de propriétés sont inacceptables alors
que la France n'est malheureusement pas
un cas isolé puisque malheureusement des
voisins européens connaissent des
parcours similaires aux nôtres mais les
propriétaires victimes de ces
occupations illicites qui font pourtant
valoir leurs bons droits se trouvent
dans des situations la puissance à
laquelle il est d'être devoir de
répondre et les maires aussi sont
démunies face à ces situations
aux chocs s'ajoute les frais de justice
les réparations et les délais
inacceptables vu égard aux différentes
situations d'un OSS circonscription
concernant ses occupations illicites il
est logique que nous représentants du
peuple français représentant des
communes nous fassions ce qui est un
autre pouvoir pour mieux protéger nos
concitoyens nous ne sommes pas seulement
face à des faits divers nous sommes face
à de véritables drames nous sommes
surtout face à une réalité le droit
n'est pas respecté les propriétaires se
sont souvent démunis voire abandonnés
par les pouvoirs publics pire ils
estiment que le droit n'est pas de leur
côté et qu'à l'inverse il protège ceux
qui occupent une maison en toute
illégalité ces situations anormales et
inadmissibles défis ouvertement
l'autorité de l'État et sa capacité à
garantir l'ordre public ce n'est pas
acceptable dans notre État de droit si
l'État ne remplit pas ses obligations
les plus documentaire comme celle de
faire cesser les atteintes aux droits de
propriété alors notre contrat social est
en péril et c'est pourquoi il est de
notre devoir de parlementaire d'agir je
ne peux que regretter que le
gouvernement perde autant de temps sur
cette question si grave parce que nous
nous sommes retrouvés en 2020 face à ce
débat et vous avez rejeté les
propositions que nous avions pu faire
et voilà des années qu'avec ma famille
politique les républicains nous
formulons des propositions qui sont
systématiquement rejetées rangées dans
les archives ou même à ce moment-là
reprise mais tardivement par la majorité
présidentielle et d'ailleurs je voudrais
saluer les travaux de notre collègue
ancien député Julia Aubert et de notre
collègue Dominique Estrosi ça sonne qui
ont travaillé sur cette question et dont
les propositions ont été rejetées en
2020 pour mémoire en 2019 Julien Aubert
et moi-même alors parlementaire nous
avions déposé une proposition de loi
visant à augmenter le quantum des peines
porter à 3 ans et des peines de prison
jusqu'à 45000 euros d'amende pour ces
délits et accroître la capacité des
pouvoirs publics à évincer les
squatteurs dans des délais rapides mais
aussi à qualifier ce délit ces
propositions présentées au moment de
l'examen de la loi on va l'appeler la
loi wargon ont presque tout été retoqué
et je le regrette que de temps perdu que
d'injustice depuis
le 1er décembre dernier les députés les
républicains devaient inscrire un texte
sur ce sujet malheureusement la majorité
présidentielle comme souvent a souhaité
reprendre une grande partie de nos
travaux et les inscrire sur leur propre
texte au lieu de faire un travail commun
avec ce que nous avions proposé mais
bien sûr ce qui compte c'est l'intérêt
des Français je regrette mes chers
collègues sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres sujets la majorité
présidentielle perte du temps avec des
stratégies politiques et des
récupérations politiciennes parce que
tout ce temps perdu ce sont des
injustices qui courent ce sont des
situations de détresse auprès des
Français et tout ça pour revenir avec
tant de retard sur ce que nous avions
déjà proposé
je dois dire que nous sommes constants
sur ces questions et que nous soutenons
ce texte avec les modifications
apportées par la commission des lois et
je vous remercier notre collègue le
rapporteur André Richard et c'est
pourquoi je vous invite à vous opposer à
cette question préalable
parce que notre souci c'est de protéger
davantage les Français les propriétaires
c'est de lutter aussi contre le recours
à une justice privée ce qui est la
conséquence regrettable d'une action
publique souvent impuissante et
considérée comme injuste comment ne pas
être révolté lorsque nous avons tous vu
des reportages ou des familles se
retrouver devant un bien qui était
occupé saccagé dégradé pendant des
années avec des frais de justice cette
situation s'est produite à Marseille
dans dans le 12e arrondissement et je me
souviens très bien d'avoir reçu les
propriétaires de cette maison et lorsque
l'évacuation a enfin eu lieu et bien eux
qui avaient été si seul pendant toutes
ces années ont vu les services sociaux
venir au secours des personnes qui les
avaient spoliées qui leur avait volé
tous leurs souvenirs qui avaient dégradé
la maison de leur enfance et pour
lesquelles il n'avait plus aucun recours
autant on peut prendre en compte des
situations de mal ce qui est tout à fait
normal mais là je trouve qu'il y a à la
fois une injustice et un aveu
d'impuissance et comme une prime aux
personnes qui trichent et qui veulent
parce que c'est du vol et qui se polie
saisonnettes Jean et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je dis que d'ailleurs ce
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui il
y a parfois pour certaines personnes des
décennies de souffrance des citoyens
honnêtes qui ont été broyés par les
travers du droit il y a même une
économie parce que il y a des personnes
qui viennent voir c'est c'est pauvres
français spolier et qui leur propose de
racheter leur maison à ville prix parce
qu'ils ont les moyens parfois peut-être
avec des gros bras ou de faire de faire
pression sur les squatteurs pour qu'ils
partent et ils rachète ses biens à ville
prix tout ça est particulièrement
injuste et c'est la raison pour laquelle
il faut protéger nos concitoyens et
surtout ceux qui respectent le droit
toutes ces personnes qui aujourd'hui
sont dans la difficulté des difficultés
nous regardent soyons leur porte-parole
et surtout espérons qu'avec une
confiance que nous pourrons redonner
dans la propriété et bien ces personnes
retrouveront confiance pour pouvoir
mettre leurs biens et le louer pour que
la crise du logement justement diminue
et qu'elle ne s'aggrave pas par les
incertitudes qui perdent les
propriétaires et c'est sur des mesures
simples que je de me demande mes chers
collègues de vous engager et de vous
rappeler que si nous sommes là c'est
pour œuvrer pour que les Français soient
mieux protégés pour l'intérêt général et
si vous me le permettez je conclurai en
paraphrasant Jaurès qui disait le
premier
je vous remercie on aura pas le temps
merci merci donc quelle est la vie de la
commission je suis désolé
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
ce sera un avis défavorable madame la
Présidente le collègue du groupe CRCE
rappelle à juste titre l'ampleur de
cette crise du logement les évoque à
juste titre le chiffre de 300100 abris 3
millions de logements en vacances ces
données des montres si l'on était besoin
la nécessité de réformer le marché du
logement mais beaucoup de propriétés
résidents en location parce qu'il
craignent d'avoir toutes les peines du
monde à le récupérer en cas d'impayés de
loyer
la proposition de loi vise précisément
rétablir la confiance pour ramener des
logements sur le marché de la location
et cette PPL vise également à lutter
avec plus de fermeté contre le phénomène
du squat qui est un phénomène distinct
je rajouterai enfin
ce cher collègue à mon avis cher Pascal
que il y a 97 amendements à examiner un
certain nombre viennent du groupe CRCE
je m'apprête à donner un certain nombre
d'avis favorable qui visent précisément
aller dans le sens que vous souhaitez
pourquoi voulez-vous qu'on arrête là la
discussion alors qu'on peut peut-être
avancer pour le bien-être à la fois des
locataires et des propriétaires dans ce
pays donc moi très franchement un avis
défavorable je vous inviterai même à
retirer cette demande de question
préalable merci la vie du gouvernement
sur le ministre
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs
notre avis sera aussi défavorable
d'abord parce que on l'a dit ce texte
est équilibré à aucun moment il mélange
les squatteurs et les personnes en
situation d'un pays de loyer à aucun
moment et le texte sera encore amélioré
et il l'a déjà été très largement par le
travail préalable de la commission
notamment sur la question de la bonne
foi
soyez vous même de bonne foi si vous
lisez ce texte vous savez bien que aucun
locataire de bonne foi finira en prison
pour pour un pays de loyer enfin je vais
quand même vous donner quelques réponses
sur la situation ce soir c'est 203000
places d'hébergement d'urgence qui sont
ouvertes dans ce pays c'est un chiffre
qui n'a jamais été atteint par le passé
par aucun des gouvernements précédents
c'est 5,7 millions d'euros qui est
dépensé 5 chaque soir par ce
gouvernement pour mettre des personnes à
l'abri et ce chiffre il est extrêmement
important il est malheureusement
difficile à
recevoir mais je peux vous assurer que
c'est un travail quotidien que nous
menons avec toutes les associations pour
arriver à cette situation le plan
logement d'abord lancé par le
gouvernement précédent c'est 440 000
personnes qui ont quitté la rue pour
aller dans un logement aucun
gouvernement n'avait fait une action
aussi forte pour sortir les gens de la
rue et ça fait partie des engagements du
gouvernement demain lors du conseil des
ministres se ferait une communication
sur le plan logement d'abord 2 et j'irai
comme je le fais tous les ans à la
présentation du rapport de la Fondation
Abbé Pierre oui pour dire que le mal
logement est un mal insupportable oui le
mal logement est un mal sur lequel nous
travaillons nous travaillons depuis des
années et une dernière chose comme mère
ou avec ce maire de Clichy-sous-Bois
largement confronté au squatteur vous
savez si aujourd'hui les copropriétés
les copropriétés dégradées sont dans cet
état là c'est parce que nous n'avons pas
toujours eu tous les moyens de lutter
contre les squatteurs si aujourd'hui la
démolition du Chêne Pointu après d'un an
de retard c'est parce que nous n'avons
pas eu tous les moyens pour lutter
contre les chasseurs les squatteurs et
vous le savez comme du Val-de-Marne
cette situation vous la connaissez
madame Lindman vous êtes aussi actrice
du logement social Vous vous ne
permettez pas des équateurs de rester
dans le logement social et vous avez
raison de le faire parce que c'est un
supportable d'avoir des squatteurs mais
oui comme vous nous protégeons les gens
en situation d'impayés de loyer oui
comme vous et j'y suis très attentif
nous luttons contre les expulsions
locatifs parce que chaque expulsion
locative est un échec et je continuerai
le faire j'ai précisé j'ai présidé
depuis que je suis ministre toutes les
CAPEX et tous les lieux dans lequel nous
travaillons pour les expulsions j'ai
réuni dernièrement l'ensemble des
énergéticiens pour qu'ils mettent plus
encore oppo dfsl parce que c'est leur
devoir de mettre au pot des FSL et pour
ma part je ne suis pas sûr d'avoir
beaucoup de leçons à recevoir merci
merci Madame Lindemann pour explication
de vote
on nous répète à juste titre quelques
cas qui sont dramatiques qui sont une
personne qui voit son domicile
habituelle
occupé par des squatteurs normalement la
loi protège déjà je ne sais que par quel
incurie du système on n'arrive pas à
faire appliquer ce qui déjà est interdit
car c'est évidemment interdit à
s'installer dans un logement de
quelqu'un j'aurais été tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'on nous explique
pourquoi la loi était mal foutue et
qu'il fallait la durcir sur ce point
deuxièmement tous les squats ne sont pas
ça tous ceux effectivement qui sont du
domicile et d'ailleurs Monsieur le
Préfet monsieur pardon excusez-moi parce
que saisis de temps en temps préféré
là-dessus monsieur le garde des sceaux
je vous enverrai la liste d'un certain
nombre de bailleurs sociaux qui
saisissent le procureur de la République
pour des squats illicites de leur locaux
de logement de logement sociaux classés
sans suite systématique bon mais passons
premier sujet ne sait pas il y a des
squats qui sont des locaux vides depuis
des lustres
occupés
par des squatteurs c'est pas bien c'est
sûr mais si ils sont pas là ils sont où
ça c'est la question que vous posez pas
ils seront où avec leurs gamins parce
que je vous parle de pas de ceux qui
occupent le domicile ils sont un film
mais cela vous pleurez pas sur leur
gosse
qui vont être où s'ils sont pas la
plupart du temps la plupart du temps il
y a pas assez de logements sociaux pour
loger tous ces gens là vous le savez
bien tous les mers le savent bon donc
déjà on aurait pu être beaucoup plus
près de pragmatique et d'ailleurs je me
rappelle le débat avec madame progacia
qui parlait bien du logement où vivaient
les gens
et puis si là où je ne comprends plus
chers collègues chers collègues c'est
pourquoi vous mettez les locataires
merci mais nous sommes solutions
je pense que d'autres moments vous aurez
à vous exprimer vous avez deux minutes
et je donnerai pas plus merci de
respecter le règle
merci madame la Présidente comme ma
collègue nous ne considérons qu'il n'y a
pas lieu de légiférer à nouveau sur la
question du squat bien évidemment que
nous sommes tous ici contre l'occupation
illicite de logement par des squatteurs
avec la loi Assab de 2020 le délai
d'évacuation d'un squatteur et désormais
de 72 heures cela permet de mettre
normalement de mettre fin rapidement aux
occupations illicites de logement je ne
sais pas pourquoi moi non plus la loi ne
s'applique pas comme elle devrait
s'appliquer et de plus depuis le premier
février 2022 un accompagnement est
proposé aux propriétaires victimes de
squat jusqu'à la restitution de
l'horlogements il n'y a pas lieu de
légiférer pour des mesures toujours plus
répressives sans effacer supplémentaire
les petits propriétaires ne seront pas
davantage protégés
[Musique]